derjenige von euch der bereit ist etwas
größeres als der andere zu machen dass
von mir abgesegnet wurde bekommt zehn
euro ich weiß nicht ob es vernünftig ist
aber meine idee ist dass ich vom heck
des bootes also von ganz oben einen
bauchklatscher ins wasser wir werden
jetzt eine woche lang mit sieben euro
pro tag auskommen nicht nur auskommen
überleben nein wir machen urlaub sieben
euro für alles jeden einzigen tag des
geistes kann sich sehen statt jetzt noch
gar nichts überhaupt hin haben sondern
das ganze bis wir haben 13 oder in
deutschland ausgesucht der erste hamburg
das wisst ihr schon die anderen beiden
sind noch geheimen werdet ihr über den
nächsten videos sehen
ja
bloß nicht so sebastian bach
nur nicht vorbei ich noch nicht vorbei
wow
wir sind angekommen und potsdamer platz
jetzt auf dem weg zu unserem vater der
wohnt hat sich in berlin ist gut für uns
daher kommen wie sie kosten kommen danke
papa ist unsere dritte letzten wieder
weise natürlich gehst wie bisher weiter
mit sieben euro am tag als budget für
alles essen unterkunft sparsam oder das
ist berlin leute dass der dritte teil
unserer sommerticket budget challenge
als gut
erst morgen wenn die leute ich war
gestern abend noch zeugen hier richtig
schöne runde und schlachten sie hier
ganz in der nähe und jetzt wo man ein
bisschen frühstück und begeben uns in
die stadt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
okay leute wenn sie jetzt in der
innenstadt angekommen wir werden jetzt
schauen was kann man den ganzen tag über
in berlin
wie immer mit sieben euro unternehmen
und na ja wo sind wir
[Musik]
jetzt hat das wunder der ruf ich hab
natürlich vorher ein bisschen geschaut
was man hier so machen kann um sich
kostengünstig berlin zu kommen und
dadurch rauskommt dass in berlin schon
mega viele trinkwasserbrunnen geboren
sie einfach kostenlos wasser trinken
kann haben jetzt gerade im gemacht on
the water frisch aufgefüllt die leute ja
und wahrscheinlich egal in welcher stadt
die unterwegs seid es gibt glaube ich in
vielen städten solche punkte an denen
man sich kostenlos wasser holen kann man
glaube ich auch also wenn ihr irgendwo
unterwegs
die kostet das wasser sparen okay das
mittagessen da wir sitzen gerade am
alexanderplatz wollen ich habe mal
ziemlich keiner mittagessen gesorgt und
zwar auf 299 ps sowie ein kühlung das
hätte aber problem weil leute wer
braucht noch verstecken was zu essen
also doch wer drin durchgeladen und so
gucken die haben sogar plastikbesteck
plastikbesteck kostet aber 1 euro 50 das
ist der klassiker haben die wir gar
nicht brauchen deswegen hatte der
geistesblitz des jahrhunderts großer
brüste der frau nachdem mitarbeiter von
supermarkt und wir haben herausgefunden
dass an irgendeiner salat war ein
gesteck kostenlos gibt es den körper
sitzt die sie für 150 preise max nicht
jetzt jeweils das mittagessen ein
[Musik]
aber dem tragischen vorfall max hat
schon wieder erwischt der war ja schon
auf der fahrt von hamburg an die ostsee
nach kühlungsborn krank geworden dass
man einen tag komplett nachgelegt
ja ich glaube ich habe ich einfach nicht
genug auskuriert und jetzt bei den
temperaturen hier hat mich einfach noch
mal voll erwischt naja ihr müsst ihr
kurzone mit weiten der prärie schicken
maxi zu hause ist das jetzt mal hinlegen
bisschen kennen und dave und ich werden
weiter cd überlegen kannst hier noch im
stadion dass wir zum fertig aus
das ist ein kleiner lichtblick und eine
sache auf die idee von der ich uns schon
ewig gefahren haben und zwar seit kurzem
sind in deutschland natürlich auch
mitbekommen elektro tretroller lega und
hier in berlin ganz viel großstädten
auch bei uns zu hause in köln gibt es
überall diese komischen rolle in allen
möglichen farben die man sich ausleihen
kann
[Musik]
übrigens hinter mir seht ist ein
original teil der berliner mauer also
wer sich alle wisst wahren geschichte
doch aufgepasst das war deutschland
mitgeteilt bis vor 30 jahren 30 jahren
ist die mauer gefallen das ist noch
erhalten das teilstück muss man sich mal
vorstellen also dass deutschland was wir
heute kennen kann man rannte irgendwo an
der tschechischen grenze und andere an
der holländischen man kann hin und her
fahren wie man lust hat wahrheit bis vor
30 jahren nicht von kassiererin
[Musik]
und jetzt hat er geht weiter wir müssen
die roller stehen lassen sonst sprechen
wir unser budget und zwei treffen hier
ein kumpel von uns den elia er arbeitet
beim ehemaligen youtube netzwerk bzw
ist ein ehemaliger kollege von dave und
bei dem schon fest
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und dann sind auch schon mal am besten
leute zu dritt packungen nudeln für 150
fertig sowie 54 macht einen euro pro
kopf ich hab mir immer macht ein
geschoss der liegt die ganze zeit schon
im bett schon geschlafen hat uns
gekommen sind
der ist komplett knockout trotzdem hat
es sich nicht nehmen das sind für uns in
diesen kalten zustand zu kochen
er wurde drücken sie damals max morgen
für das morgen ganz dicke action und wir
sehen uns morgen früh also jetzt gleich
wieder nächsten morgen leute und wir
haben eine frohe botschaft zu verkünden
max ist wieder am leben
ein bisschen schon wieder von den toten
wieder auferstanden nötig gäste mal
gesehen das was komplett raus jetzt
leute sehen wir werben schon
badeklamotten dann ist es noch mega
fröhlich hat schon spaß gemacht hat mich
den magen und wir brauchen jetzt
dringend was zu essen aber es wird nicht
immer verlaufen unser papa hat uns
nämlich eingeladen runde mit dem boot zu
fahren und es gibt eine besonderheit
denn in der nähe von dem boot gibt es
einfach ein supermarkt mit anlegeplatz
das heißt wir werden mit dem boot gleich
zum supermarkt fahren und da irgendwas
günstiges zum frühstück holen und zum
mittagessen den tag auf dem boot
verbringen und dann geht es heute abend
auch schon wieder zurück nach köln aber
erst mal abgelegt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so leute kurzem meldete ich bin's
sebastian dazu kommen kleine ich wollte
mal kurz zum bootfahren sagen weil man
das glaube ich leicht missverstehen kann
wenn es so unkommentiert in dem video
drin ist sagte dazu leute erstens ist es
nicht unsere absicht damit irgendwie zu
flexen oder irgendwie so ein unsinn aber
ich glaube das wisst ja ich auch selbst
schon das ist nicht unsere art ist und
zweitens war das ursprünglich eigentlich
gar nicht geplant dass wir das machen
aber er hat sich keine möglichkeit
ergeben und das waren 36 grad oder so in
berlin ich meine keiner hätte dann ein
gesagt aus wozu soll ich noch was gesagt
dann irgendwie falsch versteht und jetzt
weiter mit dem video müssen auf dem weg
zum supermarkt oder nicht
schreib mal in die kommentare habt ihr
das schon mal gesehen
im kopf gehabt überhaupt darüber
nachgedacht dass du mit dem brot zum
supermarkt ried bis vor einem jahr die
schau dir bestimmt dass es geht aber
hilft lange mit schlauchbooten
supermarkt zweifeln war für mich schon
mal und dann noch vier für sebastian
oder so machen wissen also sieben euro
für sebastian und sieben euro für mich
wir können gleich mal kurz heute auf
jeden fall wollen wir stabil ausgelacht
an der kasse weil wir kommen wieder los
wir sind begeistert von der sonne auf
dem wochen treibt ihr seht
wahrscheinlich auch keine videos wie ich
immer brauner werden sie immer rote
yamaha verlassen und die kassiererin
hier bei dem sogar ausgelacht und max
wartet schon auf uns also schnell zum
netz vorteil hier sind unsere einkäufe
richtig trächtig rosso ein eintopf oder
4 1 34
also für den ganzen tag essen was habt
ihr bezahlt sehen eur 46 43 personen
vier soja oder leute wir müssen es gab
noch mal sagen
die szenerie vielen dank an die deutsche
bahn dafür dass wir das möglich gemacht
hat war ja auch so wir mit dem
sommerticket in deutschland fahren
wollte deshalb jetzt verfügbar bis zum
september mein ich weiß ich habe mich
hier immer nicht eingeblendet vier
fahrten 19.90 wenn ihr unter 48 pro
fahrt mehr zwischen 18 26 sei leute wie
ich sage nochmal waren ihre jetzt ab zum
boot und ok freunde um das ganze hier
ein bisschen interessanter zu machen
habe ich mir etwas kleines überlegt
derjenige von euch der bereit ist etwas
krasses als der andere zu machen dass
von mir abgesegnet wurde bekommt zehn
euro für diese challenge das bedeutet
ihr könnt alles damit machen könnt euch
endlich das kaufen was ihr die ganzen
sieben tage nicht konnte machen was
immer ihr wollt okay ich habe richtig
craving auf so ein stück kuchen also
zehn euro sind krass rekordhalter ich
habe bock darauf mit sowas hab die
ganzen sich von seinem trading auf so
einen kaffee ich meine wir fahren ja
gleich auch noch zu politisch könnte
dann derjenige von euch das bistum
abzuholen
ich habe etwas überlegt ich würde sagen
macht einfach so ich habe es mal in der
ausdauer aus und dann entscheidet das
die krassere ist und sollte seine
casting jetzt meine würde ich mir noch
einen ist irgendwann nicht mehr
weitergehen wird okay mein vorschlag zu
zehn euro ist ihr dürft mit dem kleinen
boot rausfahren und mich irgendwo auf
diesem großen see aussetzen und ich muss
selbst schauen wie ich zurückkomme egal
ob bis 500 meter sind ein kilometer oder
so dazu muss man wissen sebastian und
ich waren schon mehr und das war kein
war keine besonders weite entfernung und
sebastian war schon am struggle sollte
ist einfach nicht auf dich selber ich
weiß nicht ob es vernünftig ist aber
meine idee ist dass ich vom deck des bot
das also von ganz oben einen
bauchplatscher ins wasser
aber das geht nicht gleich aber das
kannst du nicht machen
dein körper macht rückzieher ich glaube
wenn du selbst wenn das so runter
sprengstoff euro aufpreis sind das genau
ist halt das schlägt dein gesicht
schützen ja also wenn du es machen
solltest also ich würde ich nicht machen
ich bin ganz okay okay ich würde bisher
sagen da ist max leider ein bisschen
weiter vorne weil das weil das auf jeden
fall die sache ist die mehr wehtut die
krasser ist von
liga was tut mehr weh als hier zu
ertrinken okay das ist zwischenzeitlich
müssen zeit vergangen ich habe mir was
überlegt und zwar marx mein angebot und
nicht überbieten ist kannst du meinst du
meinst du machst hier von so der
mittleren ebene so einen bauchplatscher
ich sage dir ich ziemlich komplett aus
dem ruder ag auf die maine plattform und
springt von da ins wasser überall leute
an der seite gewinnen
es tut mir leid aber ich glaube dass wir
wirklich hart zu überbieten außer du
machst nackten bauchplatscher und ich
glaub ich lasse den vortritt und ich hab
ich nämlich einfach zurück und genießt
eine blamage das ist mir auch zehn euro
wert ja das ist richtig weil ich freue
mich auch gar nicht so sehr dass jetzt
den zuschlag bekommen und gewonnen aber
ich muss das wirklich machen ich habe
mich vorher genau richtig aber okay
[Gelächter]
für vaduz der vorteil dieser erbrachte
es geht nicht um zehn euro es geht darum
einfach auch mal was zu riskieren im
leben einfach mal seinen kompletten ruf
zu riskieren einfach wirklich wichtige
dinge für sinnlose sache zu riskieren
dass die linke
[Musik]
aber man muss überlegen was damit ein
tagescafé mehr als verdoppelt ja ich
habe eine tagesmutter für doppel
andererseits geht es einfach darum
besser als du zu sagen
also ich sebastian die us team wirklich
verdient hier sind deine tränen euro mal
sehen was du daraus machst jungs damit
machst jungs bitte wer auch immer dieses
video schneider
aber wer einmal dieses wieder schneit
kann mir bitte jetzt eine runde applaus
haben könnt ihr mit dem platz leute ich
will jetzt mein restlichen tag mit den
neu gewonnenen zenau genießen ich werde
mir schön was können und für uns geht
jetzt also weiter
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und damit schon wieder zurück in köln
leute an dem ort nehmen unsere reise
angefangen ich mir gerade in berlin noch
eine packung siege holten darin zugabe
zu rüstung als dass der herrschende
weggezogen aber zehn orte gekostet und
ihr wisst ja die sieben euro challenge
gemacht aber es natürlich nicht
selbstverständlich dass man die leute
kennt wo man bei der post an der ostsee
war einfach einer ferienwohnung kennen
kann oder auch heute das bootfahren
unser papa war natürlich auch gern nicht
selbstverständlich ist aber darum geht
es auch gar nicht so wirklich seit
mittags cruise bei unserem trip war
wirklich der besuch bei lennart ganz am
anfang und das einfach ein kollege von
sonder studien geben und das haben wir
durch so ein bisschen für uns gelernt
man muss nicht viel geld ausgeben und
sparsam um eine gute zeit haben
man muss keine krassen sachen machen
geht einfach darum zu reisen leute
kennenzulernen leuten zu treffen gute
zeit zu haben und das haben glaube ich
wirklich geschafft jetzt braucht man
nicht viel geld braucht eine geile zeit
wird mega bock gemacht haben wir die
jungs geben morgen zusammen frühstücken
auf meinen nacken leute schauen deutsche
bahn die triumphierende players mit
allen teilen da kann ich ja das war ein
zehn spielern bist du schon so weit ich
das aber augen und freunde zum nächsten
mal